[Música]
estas jóvenes iraníes están sacando de
un vagón de metro a una mujer que les
pidió que se pusiera en el velo
hace tan solo 7 meses esta escena habría
sido inimaginable en Irán La ola de
protestas desencadenada en septiembre de
2022 tras la muerte de la joven Max a
mini ha empoderado a muchas mujeres
actualmente cada vez más mujeres en Irán
han dejado de utilizar el velo en
público desafiando la imposición de su
uso por parte del gobierno
[Música]
para nuestras observadoras los cambios
que se han producido en la sociedad
iraní no tienen marcha atrás Mike tiene
35 años vive en Teherán y por razones de
seguridad solo escucharán su voz
literalmente que me mi velo hace unos
meses ya no me pongo el velo salgo a la
calle voy a café es incluso a bancos y
he viajado en avión sin ponermelo
hasta hace unos días o dos meses los
hombres y otras mujeres me sonreían
cuando caminaba en público y me decían
palabras de ánimo Bravo o estoy
orgulloso de ti
desde hace varias semanas me he dado
cuenta de que no usar velo ya es normal
la gente ni siquiera lo considera algo
especial incluso los Hombres que parecen
religiosos desvían la mirada
pero no dicen nada al respecto
todavía me parece increíble que las
cosas hayan cambiado tan rápido
dices
es como si la sociedad hubiera puesto un
manto de seguridad invisible para
proteger a las mujeres que no usan Veloz
pero la verdadera batalla contra la
República islámica Aún está por venir
dentro de unas semanas cuando empiece a
hacer calor en Teherán no veo ninguna
razón para cubrirme como lo hacía antes
ya he visto algunas chicas adolescentes
que caminen por la calle con crop Tops
y tengo muchas ganas de ver cómo se van
a vestir en verano
la respuesta del régimen teocrático
iraní fue cerrar los negocios que
contrataban a mujeres que no usaban el
velo o que atendían a clientas que
tampoco lo portaban pero el movimiento
de rechazo a esta prenda ha llegado a
ciudades más pequeñas que generalmente
son más conservadoras paranác es una
joven iraní que viaja a menudo a su
pequeña ciudad natal y también por
razones de seguridad transcribimos su
testimonio
desde hace meses veo que muchas mujeres
caminan por las calles de nuestra ciudad
sin velo y que las adolescentes hablan y
se ríen por la calle sin ponerse el
llave no usar el pasado de ser un signo
de Rebeldía o en el mejor de los casos
de rareza a un acto político una muestra
de valentía para defender sus derechos
y me sorprende ver que no era para nada
si hace tan solo seis meses no hay
marcha atrás en las últimas semanas el
movimiento ha continuado con la nueva
estrategia de realizar concentraciones
más pequeñas pero en muchos lugares
simultáneamente al menos
481 personas han muerto en las protestas
desde mediados de septiembre y otras
cintas han resultado heridas
[Música]
nuestra redacción verifica regularmente
información falsa sobre la guerra en
Ucrania y desde hace varios meses hemos
observado un fenómeno curioso
Aparentemente en las calles de varias
ciudades del mundo habría grafitis
contra Ucrania algunos habrían sido
vistos en Polonia en España y en Estados
Unidos el presidente ucraniano voló y
mirzalensky es representado a menudo
como un insecto como un excremento o
como una persona que aspira armas o
incluso dinero de Europa para financiar
la guerra en Ucrania
el 5 de febrero habría parecido otro
graffiti en Bélgica investigamos y
encontramos el lugar Exacto donde se
tomó la foto la imagen no fue tomada en
Bélgica sino en Sant mandé cerca de
París nuestro periodista cuentan fue a
este lugar dos días después de que la
foto fuera publicada y esto encontró
estoy en el lugar donde tomaron la foto
vemos esta puerta azul que de hecho es
la puerta de una agencia bancaria en la
puerta se puede ver la hoja de papel con
la flecha roja que aparece en la foto
original al otro lado está la carpa Roja
de una carnicería de las que se ve una
parte en la foto y en el piso las marcas
del pavimento son idénticas como podemos
ver no hay señales del graffiti no hay
rastro alguno de este graffiti la
alcaldía de santés afirmó no haber
intervenido en este lugar para ahorrar
el graffiti y Ninguno de los empleados
de negocios cercanos lo vio a pesar de
ser muy llamativo lo mismo ocurre con el
resto de los supuestos grafitis nadie
los ha visto verificamos cada una de
estas fotos con herramientas de de
imágenes algunos filtros detectan
anormalidades como aquí donde la parte
azul sugiere que se hizo una
modificación o aquí donde la calidad de
la imagen Es diferente a la del resto de
la foto Esto indica un posible montaje
fotográfico de hecho los únicos que
hablan de estos grafitis son los medios
de comunicación rusos por ejemplo aquí
en noviembre con estos supuestos
grafitis en París o aquí de nuevo con
este otro supuestamente realizado en
Varsovia Entonces cuál es el objetivo de
todas estas imágenes se lo preguntamos a
iliaver periodista exiliado de un medio
ruso independiente Que investigó estos
grafitis falsos Yo diría que la
estrategia detrás de todos estos
grafitis es mostrarle a Rusia que Europa
no está unida
y que el apoyo que le da a Ucrania
debería disminuir pronto
Y entonces por supuesto Rusia ganará
el principal objetivo es el público
interno
esto se por todos los medios y todos los
medios de comunicación en Rusia están
controlados por el estado
esto es parte de la gran estrategia de
zombificar a la gente sé que es una
palabra muy fuerte pero creo que en este
caso es muy acertada
[Música]
y así llegamos al final de los
observadores por esta semana si desean
ponerse en contacto con nuestro equipo y
hacer parte de la red de observadores
todos nuestros contactos aparecen en sus
pantallas hasta la próxima semana